Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Wer diesen Kanal verfolgt der weiß,
ich bin sehr großer Marvel-Fan. Und
genau deshalb haben wir hier schon einige
Marvel-Heldinnen und –Helden durchgesprochen.
Magneto, Wolverine, Mystique, Professor Xavier.
Aber natürlich sollen auch alle DC-Fans
nicht zu kurz kommen. Deswegen jetzt
endlich mal eine Folge nur für Euch. Wir
besprechen heute ausschließlich DC-Figuren,
kommt also mit. Wir gehen tief runter auf
den Meeresgrund, mit Aquaman, tief runter
in den Temperaturen, mit Killer Frost und
tief rein in die Atome mit Dr. Manhattan.
Lass uns mal mit ihm hier starten, mit Aquaman.
Er hat sich schon in den 60er-Jahren relativ
unfreiwillig einen Ruf als Witzfigur erspielt und tut sich auch ein bisschen schwer damit, den wieder loszuwerden.
(Ich sagte es schon und ich sage es wieder. Aquaman ist scheiße.)
Auch bei mir hat sich dieses leicht Lächerliche eingebrannt. Aber ich sage mal so Jason Momoa als Aquaman in den DC-Film
ist natürlich eine Superbesetzung, um hart
an diesem Image zu arbeiten. Was denkt ihr denn?
Ist Aquaman eher lächerlich oder ziemlich
cool? Schreibt mir das mal in die Kommentare.
Aquaman ist halb Mensch und halb Atlanta, so
heißen die Leute aus Atlantis. Und genau deshalb
kann er was ziemlich Cooles, nämlich sowohl an
Land als auch unter Wasser atmen. Ich kann das
jetzt ohne Tauchausrüstung nicht und war als
Kind tatsächlich immer ein bisschen neidisch,
dass Fische das einfach so hingekriegt haben.
Wir Menschen können diesen im Wasser gelösten
Sauerstoff nicht aufnehmen, sondern eben
nur den der in der Luft vorhanden ist.
Und deswegen stellt „MaxiMayerTv!“ genau die
richtige Frage: Wie kann es eigentlich sein,
dass Aquaman unter Wasser atmen kann?
Wenn Ihr jetzt denkt, dass das eine super
besondere Fähigkeit ist… Nicht ganz. Denn in
der Natur kommt das tatsächlich einige Male vor.
Es gibt einige Spezies, die das draufhaben und
welche das genau sind, das erklärt uns jetzt mal
jemand der sich mit Tieren bestens auskennt.
Mein Science-Kumpel Dr. Karim Montasser vom
YouTube-Kanal „Der Tierarzt“. Karim sag mal, wie
könnte das bei Aquaman jetzt genau funktionieren?
Hey Jack! Aquaman hat ja vermutlich eine
menschliche Lunge und dann noch irgendein System,
womit er unter Wasser atmet. Aber damit ist er
im Tierreich nicht der einzige, Seeschlangenzum Beispiel.
Die haben eine Lunge, können aber
zusätzlich, beim Tauchen, Sauerstoff über die Haut
aus dem Wasser aufnehmen. Diese Hautatmung
funktioniert aber nicht bei allen Tieren,
sondern nur bei denen mit dünner Haut. Die
Haut der Moschusschildkröte zum Beispiel ist
einfach zu dick und verhornt dafür. Deshalb
hat diese Schildkröte einen anderen Trick,
um unter Wasser zu atmen. Sie hat so genannte
Papillen ihrer Mundschleimhaut über die sie den
Sauerstoff aus dem Wasser aufnehmen kann. Und dann
gibt es natürlich noch das Beispiel,
dass ganz viele von Euch kennen, der Lungenfisch. Er hat
für über dem Wasser eine Lunge, wie wir, und atmet
unter Wasser wie ein normaler Fisch mit Kiemen.
Dann hat Aquaman also gleich eine ganze Reihe
an Vorbildern und Optionen für seine Atmung.
Aber Karim, das musst Du jetzt noch einmal
genau erklären. Wie funktioniert so
eine Unterwasseratmung im Detail?
Erstmal wichtig zu wissen: Bei der
Unterwasseratmung nehmen Tiere den im Wasser
gelösten Sauerstoff in ihr Blut auf. Also nicht
den Sauerstoff, der Teil des Wassermoleküls ist,
sondern das, was so frei rumschwirrt. Die
Haut, die Pupille oder die Kiemen sind
von Wasser umgeben. Und wenn jetzt im Blut der
Sauerstoffgehalt geringer als im Wasser ist,
dann kommt es zu einem Partialdruckunterschied. Das
heißt, der Druck des Sauerstoffs im Blut ist
niedriger als der im Wasser. Und weil das gelöste
Gas das ausgleichen möchte, strömt Sauerstoff
durch die Haut, die Pupille oder die Kieme vom
Wasser ins Blut. Und genau umgekehrt funktioniert
das Ganze dann mit dem Kohlendioxid beim Ausatmen.
Im Prinzip ist das genauso wie bei uns Menschen in
unseren Lungenbläschen. Wir können aber leider
nicht unter Wasser atmen, wie jeder weiß,
weil unsere gesamte Lunge für Gase designt ist.
Es wäre einfach sehr schwierig, über die kleine
Öffnung der Luftröhre genug Flüssigkeit
reinzubekommen. Und außerdem ist im Wasser
viel weniger Sauerstoff gelöst als in der
Luft. Das ist einfach nicht genug für uns.
Und das könnte für Aquaman tatsächlich zum
Problem werden. Denn während er an Land nur
14 Mal pro Minute ein und ausatmet, müsste
er unter Wasser, um auf dieselbe Menge an
Sauerstoff zu kommen, schon 80 Liter Wasser
durch seine Kiemen ziehen. Also 80 Liter und
das jede Minute. Das ist schon ziemlich krass.
Zugegeben, in den Filmen ist er natürlich recht
schnell unterwegs. Da kommt also eine Menge
Wasser durch seine Kiemen durch.
Also wenn er wirklich mit Vollspeed durch die Ozeane düst,
dann könnte das vielleicht sogar funktionieren.
Als nächstes kommen wir zu Killer Frost. Auch
sie beherrscht Wasser aber ein bisschen andersals Aquaman.
Denn bei ihr geht es die ganze
Zeit um Kälte und Eis. Ihr ganzer Körper ist
quasi Permafrost. Also sie hat andauernd eine
Körpertemperatur von unter 0°C und deswegen
kann sie auch so krasse Sachen machen, wie
Eisstrahlen aus ihren Fingerspitzen abfeuern.
Das macht sie, indem sie die Wärmeenergie
aus ihrer Umgebung absorbiert.
Das heißt, für ihre krassen Skills braucht sie prinzipiell
Hitze. Denn in einer kälteren Umgebung kann sie
ja keine Energie abgreifen. Da ist sie also quasi
machtlos. Dafür machen sie Flammenwerfer nur umso
stärker. Manchmal kommt es dabei leider auch vor,
dass sie die Wärmeenergie von Menschen abgreift.
Und das stelle ich mir super unangenehm
vor. Wenn sie Dingen also Wärme entzieht,
dann werden diese Dinge natürlich eisig kalt. Und
da kommt Thermodynamik ins Spiel. Deswegen habe
ich meinen Lieblingsphysiker Henry gefragt, ob
Killer Frost eigentlich physikalisch möglich wäre.
Hey Jack! Es gibt ein ziemlich einfaches, aber
wichtiges Gesetz in der Thermodynamik.
Das besagt, dass Wärme immer von Körpern mit höherer
Temperatur hin zu Körpern mit niedrigerer
Temperatur fließt. Aber niemals andersrum.
Temperatur bedeutet für uns erst mal,
wie warm oder wie kalt etwas ist. Auf molekularer
Ebene bewegen sich aber Teilchen, also Atome undMoleküle,
bei höheren Temperaturen schneller.
Wärmeenergie ist also so etwas wie die
Bewegungsenergie von Teichen. Und diese
Bewegungsenergie können die Teilchen durch
Stöße mit ihren Nachbarn abgeben. Wenn ich zum
Beispiel mit meiner Hand ein Eiswürfel anfasse,
dann stoßen die Atome meine Hand gegen die
des Eiswürfels und geben einen Teil ihrerBewegungsenergie,
also ihrer Wärmeenergie, ab.
Dadurch bewegen sich die Teilchen des Eiswürfels
schneller, sie werden also wärmer, und die
Teilchen meiner Hand bewegen sich langsamer,
werden also kälter. Aber es gibt keine
Möglichkeit, dass meine Hand irgendwie Energie
aus dem Eiswürfel rausziehen kann, um noch wärmer
zu werden, während der Eiswürfel noch kälter wird.
Schade! Wäre schon ziemlich cool, wenn das
so funktionieren würde. Aber da können wir
für Killer Frost zumindest festhalten, dass das
hinhaut. Also sie zieht sich ja die Energie nur
aus den wärmeren Objekten und verstößt damit
zumindest erstmal nicht gegen Naturgesetze.
Aktuell ist Killer Frost, beziehungsweise
Frost, wie sie da heißt, ein Hauptcharakter
im Arrowverse. Nämlich in der Serie „The Flash“.
Da gibt es eine Szene, da schießt sie einen
Eiszapfen auf ein Bedienfeld drauf. Das wirkt
jetzt vielleicht erst mal ein bisschen komisch,
dass da ein Eiszapfen einfach so
entsteht, quasi aus der kalten…
Aber es ist nicht völlig unrealistisch.
Denn in unserer Umgebungsluft ist permanent
Wasserdampf vorhanden, mal mehr, mal weniger.
Deswegen sprechen wir auch von Luftfeuchte.
Diesen Wasserdampf könnte sie tatsächlich mit
irgendeinem Mechanismus nutzen, um daraus einen
Eiszapfen zu machen. Die interessante Frage ist
jetzt also, ob in einem normalen Raum genug Luft
und damit auch genügend Wasser vorhanden
ist, um daraus einen Eiszapfen zu machen.
Ich nehme mal an, der Eiszapfen wiegt 500g und
da das Ganze drinnen spielt, nehme ich weiter an,
dass wir da eine gemütliche Raumtemperatur
von 21°C haben. Für Innenräume wird außerdem
eine Luftfeuchtigkeit von 50% empfohlen. Und mit
diesen Annahmen macht das Ganze so ungefähr
9,16g Wasserdampf pro m³ Luft. Für einen 500g Eiszapfen
brauchen wir also einen Raum mit 55m³. Und das
entspricht einem Raum, wenn wir den als Würfel
annehmen, von 3,8m mal 3,8m mal 3,8m Kantenlänge.
Okay, das ist gar nicht so groß. Und wenn wir uns
den Raum aus der Szene anschauen, dann haut das
locker hin. Das heißt, genügend Wasser für einen
Eiszapfen hat sie. Die andere Frage ist natürlich,
wie sie dieses Wasser jetzt genau kontrolliert,
damit da am Ende ein Eiszapfen draus wird.
Naja, sie müsste im Prinzip wie ein
Luftentfeuchter funktionieren.
Die Dinger gibt es ja für Innenräume. Da sind
Ventilatoren drin, die die Luft ansaugen und
anschließend abkühlen. Dadurch kondensiert
das Wasser, wird also flüssig. Und gerade
dieses Abkühlen sollte für Killer Frost ja kein
Problem sein, denn sie ist ja aus Permafrost.
Wie das Ansaugen funktionieren könnte, haben wir
schon in unserer Kirby Folge geklärt und dadurch,
dass sie das Wasser ja abkühlt, wird sie wärmer.
Und im Idealfall könnte sie diese zusätzliche
Wärmeenergie nutzen, um den Eiszapfen in eine
bestimmte Richtung zu beschleunigen.
Und das gibt es tatsächlich in echt. Das nutzt man
beispielsweise bei Dampfturbinen. Dort wird
die Wärmeenergie von Wasserdampf genutzt um
eine Turbine in Bewegung zu versetzen.
Also die thermische Energie des Wasserdampfs in kinetische Energie umzusetzen. Und dadurchwerden eben Rotationsbewegungen erzeugt.
Perfekt. Das hat alles total gut hin.
Das Wasser für den Eisstrahl holt sie sich aus der
Umgebungsluft, mit irgendeiner Superpower
(die wir jetzt nicht aktiv sehen) könnte sie dieses
Wasser ansaugen, dem Wasser Energie entziehen,
dann wird es zu Eis und die gewonnene Energie
benutzt sie um diesen Eisstrahlen auch nochabzufeuern
Killer Frost ist also einfach
nur eine Meisterin der Thermodynamik.
Und wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass sie wirklich so
eine Saugpumpe hat, aus Permafrost besteht
und die Umgebungsluft nur feucht genug ist,
dann klappt das mit dem Eisstrahl total.
Kommen wir zu Doctor Manhattan und der ist
wirklich ein richtig krasser Typ.
Telekinese, Teleportation, Zeitreisen… Es gibt
nichts, was der Typ nicht kann,
weil er halt einfach mal Energie und Materie
kontrolliert. Zum Superhelden ist er übrigens,
wie so häufig, durch einen Unfall geworden. Er ist
nämlich in einer Maschine eingesperrt worden,
dem „Intrinsic Field Subtractor“. Dieses Gerät hat Ihn
in alle seine Atome zerlegt und am Ende hat er es
irgendwie wieder geschafft, sich komplett
zusammenzusetzen. Klingt nach Teilchenphysik…
ist auch Teilchenphysik. Und da wir nicht
nur einen Physiker unseres Vertrauens haben,
sondern auch eine Physikerin, die gleichzeitig
noch Wissenschaftsjournalistin ist, muss uns Anne
das jetzt mal erklären. Was hat es jetzt genau
mit diesem „Intrinsic Field Subtractor“ auf sich?
Hi Jack! „Intrinsic Field Subtractor“
klingt erstmal mega wissenschaftlich,
ist es aber überhaupt nicht. Der Begriff ist
frei erfunden. Das, was er meint, gibt es aberwirklich.
Nämlich Kräfte, die unsere Atome und
am Ende unser ganzes Universum zusammenhalten,
die sogenannten fundamentalen Wechselwirkungen.
Das sind Gravitation, Elektromagnetismus, Schwache
und Starke Wechselwirkung. Die werden manchmal
auch die vier Grundkräfte der Physik genannt.
Der Gravitation sind für uns,
zumindest in Form von Schwerkraft,sehr bewusst.
Es kommt uns vielleicht nicht so
vor, wenn wir versuchen vom Boden abzuheben.
Aber Gravitation ist tatsächlich die schwächste
der vier Wechselwirkungen, dafür aber auch die
mit der größten Reichweite, quasi unendlich.
Aber Gravitation ist mehr als nur Schwerkraft.
In der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie wirkt
sie auch auf die Zeit. Die Gravitation krümmt
die sogenannte vierdimensionale Raumzeit.
Die zweite ist die elektromagnetischeWechselwirkung.
Die können wir quasi jeden
Tag sehen, denn Licht ist nichts Anderes
als elektromagnetische Wellen, genauso
wie Mikrowellen oder Radiowellen.
Und dann sind da noch die Schwache- und die
Starke Wechselwirkung. Die Kernkräfte,
die schwache Wechselwirkung spielt eine wichtige
Rolle beim radioaktiven Zerfall und auch bei der
Kernfusion in unserer Sonne. Da sorgt sie nämlich
dafür, dass aus Protonen Neutronen werden und
so aus Wasserstoff ein stabiler Heliumkern
entstehen kann. Die starke Wechselwirkung
hält die Elementarteilchen in unseren Protonen
und Neutronen zusammen, also indirekt damit
auch den Atomkern. Beide Wechselwirkungen haben
nur eine minikleine Reichweite und damit meine
ich wirklich klein. Sie reichen nur ungefähr so
weit wie der Radius von einem Proton.
Und damit erreichen sie quasi nicht mehr das gesamte Atom.
Auch wenn diese Kräfte jetzt nur im ganz Kleinen
wirken sind sie trotzdem extrem stark. Also
man muss sich nur mal den Aufwand anschauen,
den wir betreiben, um Atome zu
spalten, um daraus Energie zu gewinnen.
In einem Kernkraftwerk unternehmen wir da
enorme Anstrengung. Und das zeigt uns auchgleichzeitig,
dass so eine Maschine, die alle
fundamentalen Wechselwirkungen deaktiviert,
zwar interessant ist, aber physikalisch
betrachtet natürlich totaler Blödsinn.
Und dieses ganze „wieder zusammensetzen“ von
Dr. Manhattan geht sogar noch einen Schritt über
die Physik hinaus. Denn das würde ja bedeuten,
dass er quasi „nur“ körperlich zerfallen ist,
dass sein Geist, also sein Bewusstsein, aber
trotzdem irgendwie intakt geblieben ist,
unabhängig von diesem zerfallenden Körper. Und
dass dieses Bewusstsein gleichzeitig Kontrolle
über alle Grundkräfte hat, also Materie auf
subatomarer Ebene beeinflussen kann.
Auch das ist natürlich totaler Blödsinn. Aber wenn
Dr. Manhattan irgendwie die Fähigkeit hätte,
diese vier Grundkräfte der Physik zu beeinflussen,
dann könnte er natürlich außerhalb seines Körpers
existieren und hätte den dann wahrscheinlich
nur, um von Leuten wahrgenommen und angesprochenzu werden.
Und dann könnte er auch so Sachen wie
Teleportation machen. Also sich selbst zerlegen,
an anderer Stelle wieder aufbauen. Er könnte
größer und kleiner werden oder beliebig viele
Kopien von sich anstellen und dass alles
nur, weil er vier Grundkräfte beherrscht.
Zumindest das Kräfteverhältnis zwischen
Marvel und DC ist mit dieser Folge wieder
ein bisschen ausgeglichen. Aber wenn ihr noch
DC-Heldinnen oder -Helden habt, die wir für
Euch durchsprechen sollen, dann lasst doch gern
einen Kommentar dazu da. Und schreibt auch gern,
wie euch diese Folge hier gefallen hat. Ich sage
auf jeden Fall danke an Karim, danke an Henry
und danke an Anne fürs erklären und freue mich,
wenn ihr diesen Kanal abonniert und die Glockedrückt.
Dann können wir uns nämlich ganz bald
wiedersehen. Ich freue mich drauf, bis dahin!